We see it in movies and TV shows all the time
- birds delivering messages. Whether it’s
a historical drama, or the ravens in Game
of Thrones, one has to wonder - can birds
actually deliver messages with accuracy?
Not to burst your fantasy bubble, but Ravens,
while incredibly intelligent, aren’t the
likeliest of birds to get this job done. Sorry
John Snow! But the somewhat surprising fact
is that other birds, such as pigeons, are
fantastic at it! Hence the name ‘carrier-pigeon’.
In fact, they were successfully used nearly
3000 years ago to declare the winner of the
Olympics, abroad.
Pigeons have an innate homing ability, meaning
they will return to their nest to mate. Flights
as long as 1800 km have been recorded. Because
of this, they have been used for centuries
to send messages, but - and this is a pretty
big but - they generally only sent messages
in one direction. They would be taken away
from their homes, and when needed, could send
messages back home, because their natural
instinct was to fly there. So the idea of
sending a bird wherever you needed it to go
is a little farfetched. However, by placing
their food at one location, and their home
in another, pigeons have been trained to fly
back and forth between 2 locations reliably.
They have great eyesight, and use the sun
and the stars, landscapes, odors, sound waves
and potentially even the earth’s magnetic
field to locate home. Not to mention, they
seem to have an internal compass which orients
them. And because of their migratory behavior,
they can be trained as flocks, as opposed
to other birds which would require one-on-one
attention to accomplish the task.
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting
this episode and giving you a free audio book
of your choice at audible.com/asap. Audible
is the leading provider of audiobooks with
over 150,000 downloadable titles across all
types of literature. We recommend the book
“How We Got To Now” by by Steven Johnson
which covers six innovations that made the
modern world. You can download this audio
book or another of your choice, for free,
at audible.com/asap. Special thanks Audible
for making these videos possible!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!